all right jason and tasha
jason and tasha where are you guys from
missouri springfield missouri
and you guys are married no we're
together for four years
pretty much married and uh tell me about
how you grew up
jason i grew up uh with a biker as a
father
and uh mom wasn't around when
when i didn't meet her we were doing
drugs immediately so i grew up in a
uh environment where drugs were accepted
and passed around even as
children so we grew up kind of fast so
drugs drugs came into your life
real early about 13 years old i was
doing drugs
what kind of stuff like heroin was my
first addiction
yeah was uh well strong opiates morphine
oxycontin
then it would switch to heroin later on
when i ran out but
and how would you describe your
childhood uh traumatic
yeah what kind of stuff is going on uh
violence
uh like
a lot of violence a lot of drugs uh
a lot of in and out of state custody and
kidnappings and
stuff so natasha tell me about your how
you grew up
um pretty much kind of the same um by
your family
um dad wasn't around mom wasn't really
around much either
went to kansas for a while i mean
i was emancipated i started cooking
drugs before i did drugs
i was making drugs at six years old and
i didn't start doing drugs since i was
almost 30. and then when i did do drugs
i just went hard on them
real hard it was me it was everything i
would do would have to be a needle there
wasn't any needles i wasn't getting into
it
um
i raised my brother how was how was your
childhood any
traumatic events yeah i was yeah
real term active events being a biker
family and being a girl isn't
all that it seems it should be it's
really not that
it ain't fun you think it's about the
time but it's not funny
so abuse of what sort yeah violent
yeah sexual abuse yeah my ex-husband
uh had me kidnapped he kidnapped me and
getting secluded for my family for three
years i couldn't talk to them and i had
two kids in that time
because they didn't get to see and then
they finally got to see them later on
but how far how far do you guys go in
school
i ended up getting my uh high school
equivalency in prison
but i made it in school to ninth grade
ninth grade yeah same year ninth grade
first day of ninth grade and then you
guys met how
uh my job yeah i took her job
as a manager at a call center and uh
we were doing really well got a uh house
a car
had my kids yeah we were doing well and
then
an event took place in the front yard of
our house
and uh ended up losing my job
my house my id everything
at that point so we decided to go on
vacation to california
boom came out here and
uh once we came out to california the
series of unfortunate events just
continued
like cascaded into a year on skid row
so tell me about your year on skid row
mine i
enjoyed it i i actually did i didn't
have
i saved the rescue mission for about
three months union rescue mission
union rescue mission is one of the big
bigger missions here yeah right there on
skid row yeah
and then from there when the kobe came
out
i got me a tent and set up on third in
maine
and that was crazy that
that was crazy and then they put in a
hotel for a while i was there for about
two months and until he got here and
then once he got here i
forfeited the hotel because he couldn't
stay there with me i got here
and the homeless had taken over
grant uh not grounded for riot
black lives matter group had taken over
that park entirely it was like living
there
and there were riots every night like
right helicopters with spotlights and
goon squad up and down the streets it
was crazy
front page i got my jaw shattered the
first day i was here i lost track of her
and was lost in downtown
like three in the morning i'm yelling
for and like i don't know where i get
surrounded
like picked up off the ground by a
horseshoe bike lock hits me right in my
jaw
so who shattered your jaw uh some really
really huge black dude my good three
buddies
but like yeah and was there something
you were doing that
no no he was at third yeah i was just
looking looking like i had a little bit
of money
for me and yelling for her at three in
the morning where are your sister yeah i
was
completely oblivious to the fact that i
was in the projects
running around screaming for my white
girlfriend and i was like
like and now looking back i know it was
ridiculous
you guys you guys lived in a tent yeah
and i just saw i just found you at the
greyhound station you're getting ready
to go back to missouri yeah you found us
on the last day of our
nice craziest adventure ever staying
right here and that's the same thing
what kind of stuff have you seen in your
time here oh man
we have saved i've seen several lives
several people die
uh i think this dead lady in this tent
all showed up going like this and some
dude doing some voodoo
stuff it was wild she was old i mean she
was
been dead for a while for long
yeah it was creepy you see things out
here that are like
they're not even human anymore they
don't even stop chilling
out the tree yeah there's this chick she
was just
completely possessed to a point where
she didn't feel no real plan
no real pain at all she's slapping her
head off this tree and they're here
yeah it's just like and it's laughing
sickening
every time she slaps her head off this
tree then she just laughs and like
rips her chunk of her hair out and i'm
not going for her chance yeah i'm like
what and i have no treasure grabbed my
shoes and she's like 20 years old and
kind of pretty and you're just like like
what
happened i'm like what happened to you
like damn but a month later she was
normal yeah completely normal like it's
never happened yeah
so what what drugs do you guys play
around with now uh a little bit
well i play around just a little bit
anything but i
just do mess yeah and i spoke a lot so
we smoked
a lot and how do you guys support
yourself uh
pretty much out here uh it's through a
little
little bit of selling of drugs by enough
to where i can
sell a little bit and pay for my
addiction really that's about it
everything else gets fed to us
and tasha are you doing what a lot of
the ladies do sometimes yeah i just i
tell the drugs a lot um mess out here is
like cash
if you get messy you can have anything
you want no but what i was referring to
is
do you do you date guys for for money no
you don't
because everybody thinks that she does
so yeah
i get yeah i know when she chooses a
dress like this
this isn't so she's like
i usually wear it gets me in a lot of
fights
because yeah i like to dress crazy do we
either you have kids
yeah we both do yeah i've got two kids
i've been running together
yeah i've got two none together though
and
who's raising your kids i my daughter's
mom
and my kids are staying with my stepmom
and my dad
and so yeah so you'll go back to
missouri and do what
go back to my kids yeah i'm going back
to see my father before he dies
actually he's in a retirement home even
though
we had a rough childhood he's still my
hero and he was a great man so
i just i don't blame him for it because
i don't think he knew him better
i i just think it was just he was a part
of his environment you have to
understand that
these people that we all see is guilty
yeah probably went through something
equally bad exactly exactly
because if i was to be mad at him then
i'd
have to be mad at myself too because i
did i've done the same thing with my
daughter forgiveness is the answer
what's the most important lesson you
guys have learned don't take nothing for
granted
don't have valuables yeah don't get
caught up on material things
because material things aren't what
matters it is it's not
what you got is who you got your word
i always say you're gonna do something
so you're gonna do something make sure
you go through with it you know
yep i've had some of the best times of
my life out here on skid row
and definitely had some of the worst i
said we need something you gotta
give it to them man they're some of the
coolest they're some of the coolest
nicest realest people out here really
for real they will do anything for you
the latest at the same time there's
people there
[Music]
play the role yeah and then take care of
everything yeah
and kick you in the nuts yeah we've had
our tent burned down twice
yeah i had mine ripped apart by the
protesters
and pea thrown at me and spit on because
i was white
how was it how was your year here
changed you
my jaw is shaped a little different now
i'm a little more
i'm a little bit more bossy i i'm meaner
now
now i know if i can make it here in
california and on skid row
so i could be anywhere now when people
approach me
i'm not necessarily so nice at first
like i used to
i used to welcome anybody like
i don't know i wanted to talk to anybody
i was a salesman that's what i love to
do i'd talk to anybody
now when now when people approach it i'm
like what do you want yeah
like step back give me six feet i'm
gonna freak out
what the hell do you want he uh
doesn't quite like the way i dressed so
much it messed me up it was a trip it
was a traumatic experience getting my
teeth knocked out like that
i didn't even go to the hospital for my
job i was too scared i was like
no i fell asleep that night wrapped
around a bush out front of the hospital
because i went to go into the hospital
and like when i when i walked through
the door
i'm like i'm covering my mouth and [ __ ]
because this is before face masks were
real bad
and i'm covering my mouth and i was like
they're like can we help you i'm like
uh i gotta go get my wife out of the car
real quick and i ran back out and
hit her under bush i still hadn't even
found her until the next day when i
walked like four miles
still completely lost [ __ ] little
time before i took him
yeah i was like four blocks from where i
was supposed to be
but in l.a that's a big deal especially
when you're not
from here i had no idea where i was
it was horrible it definitely put up all
uh all shields i was like
relationships don't really know right
here your fullest
no relationships don't last long like
everybody everybody hates the fact that
we're together because
nobody has a lasting relationship out
here that is a difference
once drugs become part of the picture
your priorities change
yeah absolutely how does it stay the
same yeah we're still we're faithful to
each other
it's remarkable you guys have stayed
together yeah yeah
both of us have already been conquered
by drugs once and
like kind of we just play with them now
yeah now now we just use drugs because
that's
literally what we've always done it's a
form of self-medicating but really
i can't function unless i do use drugs
to at least
a small extent i have to use at least a
little bit of drugs or else
then i'm not able to function like
i don't know i've always worked uh a
good job
and been on drugs like i mean to
some extent if i of course every time i
get too far out there on drugs i'll lose
my job and everything but
i quit doing drugs for a lot yeah yeah
both of us do
we'll quit using a drug if we if we
start using it too much we'll stop for a
little while
and it's always at different times too
so it's really weird
the way it works well it didn't just
quit shooting dope she quit like
five months ago yeah everybody's still
doing it and i'm like nope i'm done
i don't want to do like that anymore
i'll soak it down but do you guys feel
like you're the childhood
environments or the families you grew up
in kind of i guarantee it
absolutely put you where you are yeah
yeah shaped us for it because there's
there's no way a normal person is gonna
get just dropped off out here
and be okay there's no way you're making
a skid row beat a female
a white female yeah by yourself
and sell the drugs and live where i
lived it's
i'm surprised i've had a fight like four
or five times in one day before because
of it
yeah because yeah it's ridiculous
all right all right you guys i'll let
you guys i'll take you back to the bus
station
thank you so much